june shows coming up june 24th i'm in
des moines iowa one night only june 25th
headed to omaha nebraska one night only
and back at brea california
june 30th one night only as well get
your tickets to those shows and all
shows at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media thank you all for the
support of this show it continues to
grow monthly i can't thank you enough
for that please subscribe to the youtube
channel it's right there boom it's free
it really helps out a lot get those
[ __ ] numbers up you know what
i'm saying y'all the patreon the
honeydew with y'all it is
it is a joy to sit and talk to y'all all
right we're coming up here on i don't
know how many episodes now and that
continues to grow every month too and
you guys do not let me down the stories
are unstoppable if you're in on it
sign up for the year get over a month
free it's five bucks a month and you're
getting the honey do a day early ad-free
at no additional cost all right now you
know what we do over here we highlight
the low lights i always say these are
the stories behind the storytellers it
is a pleasure ladies and gentlemen to
have here for the very first time please
welcome paige jenn welcome to the
honeydew page thank you i'm giving you
that love thank you we've been hanging
for
i do feel bonded this is the first
podcast i've ever been on for real yeah
outside of yours yeah but you guys have
a huge [ __ ] following and you've
never been a guest on any other podcast
no well [ __ ] i was supposed to
join a couple but just never worked out
all right so here i am well here you are
give him that five bucks please
all right well before we begin please
promote everything and anything you'd
like put it all out there
got my instagram at paige gin
and then facebook same twitter page
underscore oh [ __ ] i think it's too
understood
we just won't promote the twitter yeah
it's fine yeah just paige gin
and your podcast and the podcast the
viral podcast with chelsea land that's
right we do weekly podcasts and it's
just so much fun just talking you know
just sitting here and talking
i love it and you guys have a connection
that is it's i think is what makes
podcasts that are like your special is
you have that rapport you have that
second hand you just like read each
other
um the first video i mean i've known
chelsea for a minute now but the first
video i saw you in
was the viral video where you farted
purple powder
and i told you earlier it's like for me
it's like the sopranos anytime the
sopranos comes on i watch it anytime
that [ __ ] video pops up i'm
watching you're clicking oh god it is
great
it is [ __ ] great
people love the powder out of that it's
nuts you i know you've seen it but if
you haven't seen it go watch that that's
on the instagram hopefully it doesn't
get deleted they've been going through
my page deleting [ __ ] they really have
yeah even old stories no do they notify
you or is it just gone when you wake up
yeah i just wake up and then i get on
instagram and goes your account may be
deleted and then
yeah then they go through my account
when i'm sleeping and delete [ __ ] and
then i have to review the post and never
gets brought back that's crazy yeah i
hope they don't get that purple fart vid
though oh man it lives everywhere at
this point though yeah that's not gonna
be defeated yeah keep sharing that
[Laughter]
frick
all right so i wanna get to know more
about you because i really don't know
much about you i'm a fan a huge fan i
laugh at your [ __ ] non-stop you guys are
great thank you and um tell me a little
bit about yourself growing up you're you
said you're one of eight kids right yes
i'm the youngest of eight
and i just where are you from in utah
duchene utah the ah yeah
so the population is around 1700 please
say your high school mascot's the
douchebag
pretty much but the eagles
yeah
yeah same [ __ ] but uh yeah 1700 people
in the town my graduating class was like
i think 32
yeah 32 yeah so it's like 9th grade
through 12th grade 400 people y'all
everyone knew everyone everyone knew
everybody's business that kind of [ __ ]
yeah everyone knows who everyone's
[ __ ]
you know the whole nine yards and you're
the youngest so your your siblings
before you have already trailblazed a
path of good or bad through these
schools that you're about to attend yeah
mostly like oh i [ __ ] your sister you
know
those types of things
are you serious yeah you know you
already know though you know because
i've already heard it by the time they
tell me that's the type of town i grew
up in
but yeah so my dad had four kids with
his first wife and then four kids with
my mom so yeah my oldest sister is gonna
be 50. this
this year how old are you i'm 27. so
there's what 23 years between you guys
holy [ __ ] something like that that's a
lot of years
okay and so are you close at all yeah
all good
all of us so my parents are actually
still close too and my mom is remarried
so yeah my parents got divorced when i
was why
they just you know
grew differences like my dad is
wild like he's probably the reason why
i'm like blowing the farts out of my ass
you know all crazy
and my mom's just like very
my mom's just like very just to herself
and like the sweetest woman ever but
what does your mom think about the stuff
you do she's just like can you please
quit saying like oh my [ __ ] like
because her friends played at work yeah
yeah she's always texting me that like
hey how do i block you on snapchat
because like it just goes off like if
i'm like going like uh just to throw
people off but yeah she she's kind of
used to it by now you know your dad love
it though yeah my dad just
he loves it we grew up with him just
being like most crazy he loves to get
laughs out of people so
yeah
that's yeah that's where i got the
the [ __ ] coming from
so what's it like being the youngest of
eight are you being watched by your
siblings a lot growing up and is it like
just a lot of in and out and
like
every all hands on deck or nah
yeah like our older sisters would pretty
much let us get away with anything and
we would love to like i would prank my
sisters
like with the fake falls that's kind of
how i started fake falling and that's
like how my social media grew but
yeah i would like run and have like my
pants fall down to my knees and just
like topple over and like fake cry and
not do this in walmart or something turn
around and like all of my family would
just be scattered they wanted nothing to
do with yeah they're like [ __ ] this
so
yeah they always kind of knew i would be
like
the class clown and pulling pranks and
[ __ ] but they were the best sisters ever
like what's some of the [ __ ] you feel
like maybe you got introduced to a
little early oh bro everything
yeah
alcohol how are you when you had your
first drink oh i think my brother like
dared me to take a shot of vodka when i
was like 12. damn
yeah and he's like and i was like i
don't feel anything he's like take
another one [ __ ] so
yeah
and then like you know i'd go up on top
of the roof and we'd like find our pants
old cigarette butts and try to light
them spark them up on the roof that's
where she's smoking too no not her we
would just find her butts on the ground
you know i thought they were up there
where she was yeah we were like trouble
like we would be watching her smoke like
damn hopefully she doesn't finish all
that you know
go light them up on the roof but
yeah our sisters would drop us off at
padres games
and
yeah they were awesome it's the best
having older siblings
did you share a room
uh for a little bit but being the
youngest all my siblings were out of the
house by then you know
yeah they're always like you lived the
best life out of all of us you're the
baby
but i was also like kind you know to my
mom and because i saw what my mom went
through with
all of my siblings so
i wanted to be kind of good you know
now i wanted to talk to you about like
um driving because you said there was an
incident and you don't drive is that
right
or you do drive because i wanted to ask
you about who to who helped you drive
when you were a kid like did your
siblings take you out for like hours and
let you drive their cars and [ __ ]
my sister had a stick shift so she would
like always teach me how to drive it do
you know how to drive a stick yeah oh
yeah my first car was a stick shift but
what was your first car
an acura
like
no yeah honda wait what is it a freaking
hog
yeah same freaking [ __ ] yeah one of
these little honda things and it was a
stick shift and then now i have an acura
but
yeah
i love the old stick shift until i got
get on a hill it's a little scary yeah
it is
yeah don't like it so what happened
was what with the driving oh
well the reason why i don't like to
drive is i i would say a little bit of
the anxieties pop up you know and i
think it stems from when i was in ninth
grade my best friend's dad got in a car
accident and passed away so it's just
like i don't know
if that's why like it's not even driving
like even if i'm in a car i'm like
always like freaked out if you like stop
last minute you know i'm using that
invisible brake on my side like pushing
into the floor i'm trying to work
through some [ __ ] now or if i'm in a
smaller car
like i got a ride um back with tom's
manager back to la when we went out and
did the riverside show that you guys
came to and didn't say hi or anything to
you oh yeah sorry that's okay we don't
want to bug you but um you would never
but um i sat in the back for the hour
and like whatever half right and man
i just tried to go to sleep because it
just
it just feels tight and [ __ ] back there
like i don't like it either but i
haven't had that
so he died from the crash yeah and you
were close yeah we were super close
because that tiny town i grew up in do
shine oh
me and my best friend only lived like
two three minutes away from each other
so
i was always at her house you know when
your parents
or your friends parents start becoming
your parents like that's kind of how it
was so i don't know
how did you find out
i was at school and then the teacher
like came and got me and was like hey
you're gonna have to
go home and like told me and yeah they
just like took care of me because
everybody in the town knows who the you
know an ambulance leaves the town and
you're like
you'll know the news in seconds you know
and they probably know the people
they're picking up
yeah
yeah
that is true so what kind of anxiety do
you get from driving
gosh i just
i don't even know how to explain it i
just hate
being the driver because i feel like i'm
liable for like everybody in the car
that's going through your mind while
you're driving yeah i'd rather just
drive by myself i never drive if
somebody else is around and now like
everybody in our group knows
that i [ __ ] hate driving because of
that reason
but
yeah just i'm always on the lookout like
slow down do this too no no i haven't
yeah let's knock on that wood there it's
real wood yeah i love real wood so
you're you're a little bit of a slow
down do all that [ __ ] that's my grant my
grandma never had a license but my
grandma would tell you how to [ __ ]
drive everywhere you want oh yeah i am a
great passenger seat driver i'll give
myself that one
no i know how to drive too but [ __ ]
it's scary out there especially in l.a
it is nuts out here
it is crazy driving out here people
don't give a [ __ ] they're cutting you
off they don't care either
i don't like it and my eyesight's not
the best too i just you know shouldn't
be out on the roads anyway
day or night
or
yeah that should be the soul problem
yeah
so did you have anxiety then or just a
small car like
because i do feel comfortable in a
bigger
yeah
for sure i talk about it in my act now
too like and again it's not because i
have any extra money or anything but
i've always taken like try to take an
uber xl or something like that i just
feel safer in a bigger car and i don't
want to
i just don't want to die in a stranger's
prius you know the jaws of life dragging
me out of that [ __ ] tin can let's get
a bigger car out there none of these
people are driving like they should be
driving for [ __ ] a company as their
profession oh hell no
i i don't even think you need an
application you just show up just show
up and hop in the car
put off the map there's another thing i
want to talk to you about and i know
it's a serious subject but we talked
before the show and you mentioned one of
the low lights being a friend's suicide
mind
going into that
yeah so
when i graduated from high school in
2013 i moved out here to california well
i moved to san diego and
i got a call and my one of my best
friends committed suicide from back in
from back in yeah from back in duchesne
so we grew up together like doing dance
and you know just
then she stopped we stopped doing dance
and then i started doing sports and
she's like i'm gonna do the drill team
but she lived like 30 miles out of town
like pretty far and drill teams like
five in the morning so she would stay
the night
like every night because i lived close
to the school
and she even switched schools to be
closer to like me and stuff and then
yeah once i moved out here i got the
call and
yeah
who called you my mom called me and was
like courtney committed suicide and
yeah and just in the craziest way
possible how she ran and jumped off a
cliff no yeah
i've never heard that yeah ever yeah
so a cliff
and like i've never had like therapy for
it and like
nothing so i'm like i don't know how to
grieve or like that's eight years ago
yeah nine years ago yeah 2022 now it's
just like i don't i feel like i've never
really like
just i don't know how to how to even go
about it and then like just from just
moving to san diego and then having that
all happen back home and then it's like
what do i do or like how
and death is so weird to me anyway so
why what it what about it i don't like i
think i'm afraid
i'm afraid of death
i feel like just maybe like too afraid
of it and i'm like okay well maybe
that's because like my best friend's dad
died and my
one of my best friends committed suicide
like maybe i feel like oh your life
could just be taken like that so maybe
that like
triggers something
i like anxiety when you drive yeah like
anxiety
yeah day or night blind or not yeah just
so how was she courtney yeah she was my
same age yeah 18. she was actually
younger than me so like
yeah and she was she ran
who found her
how the [ __ ] do you even know was it
days later was this like like same day
they found her car parked up there and
then there's a place you had been with
her before
no no so like
um
in high school she moved to a different
school which is only 30 minutes away
it's called roosevelt and so she started
doing drill team over there and like was
the drill team captain and just was
gonna do so much in life and then
just
what happened
uh
i
like still
don't even know she got into like a
little fight with her mom
and then
i think her mom took her phone and then
everyone's 100 sure nobody else was
there to make this
poor girl fly off that cliff that's what
they say
yeah it's it's nuts and i don't know how
to get closure you know from that and
like
yeah i don't know
how to go about it death is so weird to
me
and
i just feel like maybe i need to accept
it you know do you accept it yeah i have
to everybody so many people [ __ ] died
sooner or later you got like all right
we just gotta accept this [ __ ]
yeah i accept it i mean here's the thing
about death for me like i i'll you'll
never forget it
but you do get better with it over time
but you got to put work in if you really
want to so if you want closure from that
you've got to do something about that
right yeah that's not just going to come
it's not like
[ __ ] something's going to happen
where you're like there it is oh yeah
closure you have to go actively seek it
out like it like works all right so talk
to me about this let's talk about you
get that call do you go home for the
funeral
and and tell me all about that
yeah i just i flew home like you're just
like that same day yeah fresh into san
diego like seriously like the week
and i just dropped my knees and was
crying and i my mom's like i got you a
flight come home so i just hopped on the
plane went home went to a funeral and
then just like
i came back because i already started
just you know my life out here
and
i just it's such a like i mean did you
you were close to her parents yeah super
close to her parents like her mom used
to just take us all around to like
toilet paper houses when we were younger
yeah she yeah she has a badass mom
yeah
yeah she was freaking badass
but
yeah i feel like i haven't even really
reached out to her mom how i want to you
know like
and i haven't seen her mom like just
from the funeral like i haven't
i just
it's so hard what worries you about that
about reaching out
um
i've
i it's just hard for me to talk about
and then
i don't know like i knew she wasn't
ready at the time and i guess
courtney like left things behind too
and like
yeah she like left notes and stuff
behind and like her mom wasn't ready to
read or share you know so i don't want
to be like hey you know what to say but
she did give me like her old like drill
team jerseys and stuff yeah that's nice
yeah i was going to make some like
blankets or do something with it
yeah what um did you know her to be
depressed or suicidal at all or is this
like a was it a total shock to get that
call total shock because growing up she
was the most outgoing girl ever like she
would just be like she would see like
bugs or whatever and like
eating them she would do the fake falls
like she was so outgoing like nobody
ever expected her to be
you know to do this she's freaking
beautiful
girl team captain just
everything going for her to that and
it's a tough one for sure so you don't
know really because since you haven't
reached out or anything like what was
really going on behind the scenes or
have you heard some things later no
that's the other weird part it's just
like okay well
like is there more to it or
are they as shocked as me you know i
mean like i don't even know this girl
and hearing that she jumped off a cliff
like that's [ __ ] nuts yeah it's
[ __ ] nuts and get out of the car you
could have just drove the car over too
like it's weird yeah it's strange let me
put it that way and what a
weird like yeah it's definitely
one of the crazier ways to go out for
sure
and
yeah i feel like definitely the podcast
like the viral party has with me in
chelsea just even talking about it and
talking about being afraid of death so
many people have reached out just like
hey this is what i read or this is what
helps me like people do like rapid eye
movement and all these different things
in vr therapy yeah i've never looked
into i'm like that is something i need
to look into for sure you should
it really helped with um because
sometimes you don't know that that like
i feel like anxiety just like chills out
in us in a hammock and when it's like oh
i got called you know and it pops up and
it's like here we go you know and then
it just brings you a whole new set of
[ __ ] sometimes you're like man i'm not
i don't normally shake from the
everything else i deal with what the
[ __ ] is this yeah or whatever you know
yeah um
and i never even really knew what it
could have been until like i was in the
car and like afraid all the time and i'm
like chelsea i think i have like anxiety
about death
because i'm like every time i get in the
car i'm freaked out and so i started
like trying to diagnose myself you know
and then i'm like oh [ __ ] maybe i'm just
afraid of it and
that's what i need to work on
what do you remember most about your
friend
that's nice first of all let me let me
not just gloss over that you need to
work on it i think that's awesome that
you want to are you going to
yeah but i'm like i don't know if
therapy is
right for me or like if i just
try to help myself through this or just
i feel like talking on podcasts honestly
no doubt talking to people yeah who
reach out and say the nicest oh wow yeah
the support is like what helps me i feel
like or what people have told me what
they've done
that's what i like
it that's that [ __ ] i do like who do you
talk to about it who do you is chelsea
your go-to to talk about real life [ __ ]
and when you don't have to be stupid and
silly and
you know always on and in front of
[ __ ] like we always are yeah i feel like
i'm kind of the same
pretty much no matter what and like i
tell people because i want to be
truthful you know like i tell chelsea
the same the same thing i'm saying right
now like damn dude i don't know what it
is like and she recommended a book
called dare
and that's like about death and
overcoming it so need to hop on that too
there's just so many things going on
that it's hard to just like have some
down time and focus on yourself you're
young to have those fears that you
should be carefree yeah
in life right now yeah yeah and then
some people are like yeah in my whole
20s you know i feared death i thought i
was going to die and then once my 30s
came it just completely went away and
i'm like okay now i need to enjoy life
for what it is you know
so
three more years
maybe i'll be there yeah the secret to
life is living life the way you want to
live life that's it there's no one
secret that works for all of us it's
just being able to live your day-to-day
life the way you want to live it exactly
no not letting it live you you're living
it yeah um i asked you what do you
remember most about courtney
gosh just how wild she wasn't down to do
anything like i would drive my bike
around and just make her sit on the
handlebars and i'd just run into like
trees and buildings and we're just like
like
stuff yeah and she wouldn't know and she
would just see the tree coming up no no
no and i just hit into it and fall over
like on main street and
those are fun and the one time i was
gonna [ __ ] my pants i'm like run inside
is after chinese food i'm like run
inside and tell my dad i'm having a crap
attack hurry i'm gonna [ __ ] my pants and
she could not stop laughing she's like i
can't tell him i'm like tell him i'm
gonna [ __ ] my pants so she had to like
go inside and tell my dad she's gonna
crap my pants and just all the memories
you know i've heard there's so many but
just
yeah our childhood dancing together and
then
just going through life together and
just even her
staying with drill team and then me
doing sports and then still having a
relationship
you know
it's crazy
i'm i don't mean to ask an insensitive
question but i'm assuming it was a
closed casket at the funeral and stuff
no no no it actually was how high was
the [ __ ] cliff first of all i i've
never went and seen it don't you want to
know the answers to these questions or
do you feel like you're better off not
knowing i feel like sometimes we are but
what what do you want to know what do
you really want to know that you've been
afraid to ask
anyone her parents or anyone what do you
want to know
i guess just like more of what happened
like in the day like leading up to it or
like weeks even you know
or if they saw something what but like
or if she just went up to get fresh air
and stood on the cliff and the [ __ ]
[ __ ] broke loose and maybe it was an
accident is that possible yeah we like
dug into that like was anybody with her
what
like there's no suicide letter right
that says i'm taking there were letters
you said that no i think it was like i
don't know what she wrote yet either so
so there could be you don't know but i
think it was pretty much like
i i would say leaning more towards
suicide you've never driven up to that
cliff no
no and when i flew back like it was a
pretty quick trip and then i had to fly
back so i didn't like go up there i just
we hung out with friends like all of our
friend grew up and had a bonfire and i
do so bad at funerals too
like i mean i don't know that there's a
good one somebody out there like look no
there's a couple good ones
just
i think i don't know like i get such a
weird ass feeling like i feel like some
people are so good at handling it like
my dad will be like oh yeah i'm gonna go
talk at this funeral this that i'm like
how does he do that like
i
i'm so
bad at it just
thinking about it
weeks ahead freaking or weak
i i struggle with it for sure
maybe everybody does but no everybody
doesn't say it
you know yeah i think there are people
that get up and maybe power through it
for the benefit of others and things
like yeah you can't or won't you know
things like that yeah athletic greens is
the health and wellness company that
makes comprehensive daily nutrition
really simple with so many stressors in
life it's difficult to maintain
effective nutritional habits and give
our bodies the nutrients it needs to
thrive when it comes to parenting
touring working look i start my day
every day i put my athletic greens right
my morning shake and i love it it makes
my whole day better as the research
changes so does ag-1 while most
nutritional products that come to market
never evolve athletic greens continues
to obsessively improve ag-1 based on the
latest research producing 53
improvements over the last decade and
counting it's lifestyle friendly whether
you eat keto paleo vegan dairy-free or
gluten-free and it contains less than
one gram of added sugar no gmos no nasty
chemicals artificial anything while
keeping it tasting good to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you an
immune supporting free one year supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com
honeydew today again simply visit
athleticgreens.com
honeydew to take control of your health
and give ag-one a try a change of season
means longer days better outdoor
activities and more ways to get
healthier including checking in on your
health and wellness with everly well you
can take action today by taking one of
their at-home lab tests or by adding
their vitamins and supplements into your
daily routine with over 30 at home lab
tests you'll be able to choose the test
that makes the most sense for you to get
the answers you need everywhere also has
high quality vitamins and supplements to
support your overall health including
vitamin d3 and omega-3 fish oil here's
how it works everly well ships products
straight to you with everything needed
in one package you simply collect your
sample and you use the included prepaid
shipping label to mail your test back to
a certified lab your physician review
results get sent to your phone or your
device in just days you can even share
the results with your primary care
physician it's so simple over 1 million
people have trusted every well to
support their health and wellness goals
and you should too for listeners of my
show everly well is offering a special
discount of 20 off and at home lab test
at everlywell.com honeydew that's
everlywell.com
honeydew for 20 off your next at home
lab test
everlywell.com honeydew with all the
jargon flying around it can be hard to
figure out how to start investing
getting your money right is easier with
sofi the first investing platform to
offer stocks etfs automated investing
and cryptocurrency 2 all in one app you
can invest you have the option to do
banking credit card track your finances
and check your credit score whether
you're eager to get started with
investing or you already know the ropes
and you want to diversify your portfolio
sofi has your back no commissions or
trading stocks and etfs plus no account
fees or hidden fees use fractional
shares that start as low as five dollars
to buy brand name stocks even if you
don't have a couple grand lying around
complimentary financial planners are
ready to help with any questions whether
you're stuck on where to start or need
help deciding what to do next cut
through the jargon and make investing
easier with sofi visit sofi.com
honeydew to learn how you can win up to
a thousand dollars in stock when you
open an account that's sofi.com
honeydew brokerage and active investing
products offered through sofi securities
llc member f-i-n-r-a
slash
s-i-p-c
now let's get back to the do
it's funny you got me sitting here
thinking in my head and i'm almost
positive
i didn't but i don't think i got up and
said anything at my dad or my
grandmother's funeral i don't remember
if i did i was 16 and like
20 and i i feel like i was so all my
brothers and i don't think i said
anything i mean but maybe i did i don't
[ __ ] remember like there's that much
like i remember weird moments of both
funerals but i don't remember that's so
young yeah so did your dad pass away you
said when you were 16 yeah 16 yeah
gosh that's so hard to still just you
know but also being a parent and
thinking about a child's suicide because
i have a friend of mine whose brother
took his life um and it was it was awful
and what really sticks with me and his
name is jamie snyder he was a great kid
he was
probably i think he was 19 about the
same time like just graduating high
school he'd gone into the marines he was
having some trouble
um with a girl back here and he was in
japan i think on
on his leave and i mean not leave on on
duty and uh they he asked to come back
and just get his [ __ ] cleaned out and he
wasn't writing ahead and they said nope
you're a united states marine you're
fine it's all good he was calling the
house and like the ex was there
answering the phone and telling them
[ __ ] and so his father called and they
said the same thing your son's a marine
he's fine he'll be fine
and then um i'm not sure how many days
later but
whether it was the next day or a couple
um he did not show up for some meeting
he was supposed to be in and one of his
friends knew that wasn't right went up
to his room and he'd hung himself with
his bed sheets
and the thing that [ __ ] sticks with
me the most is that they said he had
fingernail marks in here because he
didn't want
he couldn't get it all oh my god he dug
his neck to try to get it off and he
couldn't
so i think about that all the time and i
think about like man this poor kid and
what he went through and this whole
macho [ __ ] of your [ __ ] son's
gonna be fine walk it off guys don't go
to therapy guys yeah no show your
emotion like express yourself be
vulnerable
like own it yeah vulnerable i feel like
that i feel like you're stronger of a
man if you can express yourself and
yeah really tell somebody how you feel
that's so important and then to have
someone reach out for help and be denied
that's another thing so
i mean but that's why i was getting out
with you like there were there were
signs that he was having trouble
at least but again my world i'm not in
their family i don't know if there were
suicidal
issues or if that was just the
spur-of-the-moment decision which it
feels like maybe it was and he couldn't
undo what he had done
um
but so you go back for this you've never
been to the
the cliff you've have you ever talked to
her parents since well yeah i reached
out to her mom just like you know text
and just keeping up on social media but
i've never like
gone back in for years damn near um
impossible to miss on social media at
some point if you're scrolling for like
five [ __ ] minutes
so i know they've got to see you out
there yes right yeah definitely the
whole the whole damn town you know
they they definitely see the shenanigans
going on but yeah her mom you know in my
head every year i'm like or
damn near every day i'm like i need to
[ __ ] go back to my hometown and like
just get with her mom but like maybe
that
like why is that holding me back like
why is that the hardest thing
for me to do well i know this too i just
make you my therapist that's fine i'll
give you some a little bit of hindsight
i have and i can understand your um
your hesitance because my my
i mean she's i just talked to her
yesterday she called me to wish me a
happy birthday um her name's miss sandy
she's my buddy shannon's mom and
shannon's sister's name was kelly okay
shannon and kelly were brother and
sister but brother and sister to me and
my brothers as well we had no parents
after that we were there all the [ __ ]
time
and i think when we were 20
kelly was killed in a car accident with
another friend of ours named anthony
emilio and they were in it was a rainy
night a truck across the center line hit
both of them
from what i remember they're in a 280z
um anthony blows through the t-tops and
is immediately i believe he was
instantly killed from the injury but
their heads
collided
and that
head-to-head put her in um a coma and
ultimately took her life she didn't
recover from it
and her best friend um is named rebecca
and rebecca and i are still close and we
go all the way back to this you know
childhood
um but it's been very hard for
i call her sand now but for her to watch
rebecca grow up and become a mom and do
all these things that her daughter
didn't get to do
so i know that it sort of like you know
separated them but they always will ask
each other
me how's rebecca how's my saying you
know i'm sort of the go-between when i
come into town or whatever and so is her
son but
um i get that it could be difficult so
maybe it might be difficult for her to
talk to you i don't know yeah it's one
of those things you really it's a it's a
crap shoot and maybe that's what i need
though you know like at the end of the
day maybe that's like the thing that's
just
making me feel like i don't have closure
you know well here's the other thing or
maybe i never will this is this woman's
daughter yeah this is your best friend
yeah and you just said it it's what you
may need so why not reach out to her and
say look i've been wanting to talk about
this for a while and you're the one
person i think i should talk to yeah for
sure
just like what's the first thing you
think you would ask
i guess just like what she left behind
maybe like in what sense like the
literal sense yeah or like how do we
know
like what you were saying like how do we
know for sure
like and yeah just like what happened in
that day exactly
you know because i feel like so many
things are just left unsaid and then
the rumors that come with it in a small
town you hear this that this that and
it's like
i don't want to blame anybody you know i
just want to know what without naming
people what sort of rumors were you
hearing just like oh that one of the
guys she was talking to was up there and
pushed her it's like
okay and then they were like nope like
that was shut down real quick and then
just
so many you will hear so many stories
just because you know people like to
feel
important
making [ __ ] up after people die like
yeah or like even people who never even
talk to her you know would just then all
of a sudden they were best friends with
her and knew exactly what was going on
it's like what the hell
just i wish i could and i can get that
like for sure answer
but
yeah it's uh why why you avoiding it i
don't know
you think about it yeah i think about it
yeah
and i think about it too like for her
like i
that's just the res i feel like it's
respectful to go and i feel like when i
did hold off for so long and then it
kept building up building up building up
that i feel like like why would i reach
out now but like i don't want her to
think i just you know forgot about her
daughter i mean i think it's pretty
powerful to be like for years i've
thought about this yeah
i really want to get
you know some answers and some closure
and who better to go to now it might be
tough you said she had you think she had
an argument with her mom that day and
yeah but that could have been a rumor
too you know so
it
it's like i just need to know the full
story of what went on
and then i feel like maybe that will be
like a chapter of moving forward and
that yeah for sure have they ever come
to see you perform live or any of the
shows you're on or anything like that no
because i don't really perform live yeah
you did say really ever that's more
chelsea but
yeah
and they probably watch all the stuff
so i grew up in utah where it's like
really churchy and i grew up around all
mormons like you're not no and i'm the
only one who from my town who's pretty
much not mormon so i was corrupt and
people and this and that but
yeah i don't know like how much they for
sure keep up on my social media or know
what i'm doing but
they're always supporting no matter what
now did you guys have any mutual friends
where you talk about
[ __ ] like what may have happened that
are still there that might know a little
more
i feel like all so me and my friend
rachel
and rachel's is the one her dad passed
away when we were in ninth grade and
then
we also gosh she's had so much death and
then her mom just passed away in 2022.
so so rachel's parentless yeah rachel
yeah my best friend doesn't have parents
and then
she was supposed to move to san diego
with me when we graduated but she got
she got the all knocked up
yeah yeah so she stayed in duchesne and
me her and courtney were like the three
we were the
migos you were that tight all three of
you yeah so
just
yeah
rachel doesn't know like any more than
what i know and
all of her other good good friends like
one of our close guy friends dated her
just all throughout growing up on and
off and
he had a hard hard time too but none of
us no it's just like
i guess everyone just moved on or just i
guess that was that but i feel like
there could be more yeah i mean who
wants to go out is just that's that yeah
especially one of your friends
what do you think about the most when
you think of her
just the time she made you laugh and all
those yeah
everything just the sleepovers just
everything we did everything together
seriously
every day
staying the night of my house we would
like sleep in my little twin bed
together i would like wake up with my
arms now i'm going down the hallway my
hands like smacking me in the face and
she thought that was so [ __ ] funny
yeah
but
it's rough it's rough
i hate it
and i'm like maybe that will help though
reaching out this has been building over
the years and is it getting
more and more or has it always been like
this
uh
i would say it's just i've always kind
of felt the same about it
but i don't want to feel the same about
it and i feel like it's holding me back
from a lot like what just like the
anxiety of death or like accepting it
for myself because of
because of her
and
and then we all
sorry it's just so much death but then
my
we had a other friend who lived with me
for like
a year my brother's really good friend
when we lived in san diego
so they were playing college football
together at palomar and then his friend
evan started coming over staying all the
time and we like grew super super close
to him
and then
he
they found him at the bottom of a bridge
in san diego just yeah this super
freaking
freak athletic
and was with us just all the time
partying this that like
yeah and then that happens to him too
and we're just like still
his parents live in poway and we're like
dude what the [ __ ] like
how
i'm still they found that you're oh my
god [ __ ] bad luck
[ __ ] i'm scared to leave a studio
yeah every person i talk to
watch your [ __ ] back yeah it's a trip
dude
like
what do you mean at the bottom of a
bridge it wasn't water down there was
just like one uh a bridge over land yeah
i guess a guy and his daughter were on a
walk and found him at the bottom of the
bridge just like 23 years old college
football like
was was like a i think he holds the
record in poway like in san diego for
the quickest like
100 sprint
and his parents like nobody knows
anything because there's no note left
and then he had like a half eaten
burrito in his car
and then just
that's that's
like that's that i know right that's why
you talk about half eating burrito yeah
it's it's like me and my brother the
other day are like dude we need to
figure out like what the [ __ ] happened
like
we needed even if there's like a
documentary or something like we need to
get to the bottom of this for real
because it's like you can't just say oh
it's suicide like if you
if you don't know
but then how do you go back and like
retrace or yeah how long ago was that
like 2017
yeah so that's yeah i mean at least two
ruled suicides in your life have you
have you had other people have taken
their life like that
[Music]
well my dad's sister committed suicide
when but i wasn't i was super super
young so
my dad
tells us about that and what happened
with that
uh
so my aunt dated a famous boxer named
bobby chicon chicone have you heard of
him ever i feel like i have is it
chicony or something like that yeah i
don't know yeah i probably have yeah so
he she like didn't want him to fight and
then he like became super abusive
and
she even had kids two kids and then she
took her own life
she shot herself shot herself yeah
legit mm-hmm my dad said he was like
driving up and he like
saw like
yeah
okay so your dad
lost a sister to suicide and witnessed
the aftermath
that you never [ __ ] forget
um has he been a good resource to talk
about or have you not even really talked
to him about your friend's suicide no my
dad is
crazy we're so so close and
he just is like
he's pretty religious like you know like
god like you know pray and
accept god as your personal savior and
you know
like just believe in him so
like we talked about that
i don't
i
i do believe in god but like i don't
know anything about like religion
so i think i need to tap into that yeah
the same age i was when i started like
just questioning everything yeah all of
them and especially with like the
[ __ ] world right now yeah then you
have to question just everything
everything every single thing yeah it's
all even the water you're drinking but
uh
yeah
but [ __ ]
where were we talking to your possible
uh i'm talking to you by religion and
stuff yeah
of talking about suicide you ever talk
to him about it
just
he doesn't really like guide me in a way
because i
i feel like maybe the past couple years
is when i've been like when i first
reached out to chelsea and was like hey
i think i'm like have anxiety about
death and then like that's when i
started just kind of like talking about
it and like oh the car thing that that
so i haven't really like reached out to
him for that but he would probably give
great advice let me know went through a
suicide yeah he gets emotional about it
for sure and
and he actually just had a friend commit
suicide as well jesus
yeah and in a small town it's like you
know
it's like awesome because you know
everybody but then you also know them
when they die too so it's like what
happened with this guy
was it was a girl girl yeah she
she hung herself they
they think it was like
you know the vid my dad's like i don't
think she would do that like
you know how people like do the
jerk yeah erotic
yeah i don't even know really too much
about that
choking pool yeah i just made that up
right now the choking tubs what they're
doing yeah yeah
but it was her
a woman this is not a woman does that
work for a woman
i'm not quite sure how you could get
there honestly yeah i mean because that
that would take a lot it'd take a minute
it would take a while unless you're like
right next to coming and then you kick
the chair away or something and try to
go for it yeah that would be a quick one
that'd be a lot i am
i'm generally not a conspiracy theorist
yeah but all these suicides you
just sound
yeah all of them for sure of all the
people and maybe i'm look i'm an idiot
so i but all the suicides i've heard
were it's autoerotic asphyxia has been a
man i know women like to i know the
choke and all that but
i mean
no that that one's new to me for
for the rope around the neck or whatever
the hang of yourself yeah
i
i can't dabble with that at all
but yeah he's he's very emotional he
expresses himself like he was getting he
spoke at her funeral and he's always
speaking at people's funerals and i'm
like you got a lot of them it sounds
like yeah we do speech writing but he
but people ask him like hey can you
share this story and we know she was
close to you he was close to you like he
just took a trip down here and spoke at
a funeral then yeah he's like always
speaking at funerals and i'm just like
how does he do this
when my fear is to even just show up at
a funeral you know it sounds like you
have the perfect person to talk to
actually yeah it really does gosh
sometimes i feel like we look for
answers to [ __ ] and we're looking here
and here and here and over there and
under this and sometimes it's [ __ ]
bam it's right right in front of our
face
[ __ ] yes
i mean your your dad's dealt with your
aunt's suicide first hand
and he speaks at funerals which
is something that i think is very um
unselfish and i think it's very
it's nice to to get up in front of
people and when you're seeing everybody
at their worst you know what i mean your
dad's not going into a family reunion no
he's going in and speaking and bringing
up the positives about someone who's
gone and making other people feel good
about that person that says a lot about
him yeah he's such a sweet guy
i mean you got the perfect person to
have mm-hmm he'll be like asking me like
what should i do like he'll be reading
me poems just like okay i think i'm
gonna say this and like he'll he writes
those poems or he just finds them and
he'll he'll do both and like he'll be
practicing
for days leading up i'm
what the [ __ ] is this normal
is this normal [ __ ] but yeah what a
great guy i'll be even finding poems for
him like this is a good one say this
save this from when the next death yeah
for the next one you have to host some
shady suicides on this episode
gosh i
i just keep thinking of all the people
that have like died in my brain i'm like
oh [ __ ] who else this would be a full
death episode who else have you had to
die you're gonna get like talk about it
for real there's so many people that are
scared of death so many people and i go
through waves when i was single i didn't
give a [ __ ] then you become a parent
you're like oh my god you know it goes
back and forth you know all the time for
sure
for sure i take it into consideration
every time i fly
i take it into consideration you know i
should more in a car
but i feel like i'm in control and it's
a control thing too for me a little bit
so
tell me who so you like to be the driver
yeah i do you'd roll good with me
because we would work as good as a team
i'll drive you could just sit over there
and i don't speed and [ __ ] everybody
makes fun of me oh you met my stepson
they all clown me my daughter does too
it takes me like five minutes to get
going i'm buckled i got the gps i'm not
touching [ __ ] when we're driving good i
love that yeah people on their phones
like piss me off i'm like that's so
selfish
uh yeah so
our friend
our friend in san diego that we met and
like
we had a whole girl group
and then
one of our friends from roosevelt what i
was saying do shane and roosevelt
they're like the 30-minute difference in
yeah in uh utah so one of the guys
comes out here and visits
us and then he gets close with our one
of the girls in our friend group her
name was danny
and then they were gonna like go back to
utah and after like a couple years of
dating and as soon as they get back to
utah our friend danny has a freaking
brain aneurysm
and dies where
she went in to like get a
what's it called like when you have to
put money down a deposit for she had to
show proof of income for her new
apartment and she walked in there to get
it and just
right there they said she they said she
collapsed and then they rushed her to
the hospital and then
my friend who moved down here because i
moved down here called me and was like
danny
died like like what the [ __ ] dude
like it's so
crazy and then i
i'm such a [ __ ] like i didn't show up
to her um
little like ceremony that they had
together i was just like and it was like
at the start of covid and i'm like i
can't like
physically get there like i don't know
it's so rough
it's a lot of death yeah that happened
to me too by the time i was 20 it was a
lot of impactful yeah and then
i was like oh my god everyone's dying so
yeah that's why i joke about talk about
we turn it into a family death pool like
who the [ __ ] going next yeah
and um i i get it i get where it comes
from that's a lot of death sometimes it
is like very close better to laugh about
sometimes like to make it comedy rather
than being dark
but then it's like well [ __ ] it's so
good to talk about too at the end of the
day because you know we're all [ __ ]
gonna die we're all gone we're all going
we're all going whenever i'm sure your
friend didn't see this [ __ ] coming like
it's a light switch yeah if you're done
you're done yeah
just
that's why you just got to [ __ ] live
you know every freaking day it's coming
whenever it's coming
yeah
just like a penis
you could probably help that along a
little more
[Laughter]
okay
so let me ask you this then does does
the fear of death that you have i know
we've talked about driving stuff but
does it do you feel like it really
prevents you from living the life you
want to live
like
does it play in your mind about having
kids because you're worried something
could happen to your kids does it play
in your mind about anything
not really the kid part because i don't
mess with the rubbers too often but uh
like
just anything like even what yeah the
condoms well i'm going the kid part
doesn't worry you because you don't mess
with condoms yeah you know i'm not
worried about having kids and stuff with
them i use condoms because i don't it's
not the other way you clearly yeah so if
i get pregnant and have a kid that's
that you know yeah okay because i'm i'm
putting that
chelsea over there tonight
you just gotta roll with the punches
okay so you're raw dogging
and simultaneously not worrying about
having a kid instead of
condoms and not worrying about having
the kid because you have the protection
yeah well
so you worry more about dogs for about
eight years so
you know you worry more about death than
you do about life about getting pregnant
in life yeah
that's a problem huh
you just
how is that how can you be more worried
about death than having a life inside
you
i don't know
because i'm like okay if that happens
then
i just have to deal with it
okay so here's this is interesting if i
die i'm not here
true but this is again you do not need
to answer this question at all but
if you get pregnant you said you're
having that baby
right
yeah you have the option not to at least
in this [ __ ] state still oh yeah but
you're gonna have that baby
so
does death play into that decision for
you
no
i don't even really think it's like how
i'm
gonna die or whatever it's just like the
thought of
like just like we are here humans on
earth and just like the thought of like
just like nothing or
just everyone
gone i don't know it's so freaky to me
like why are you i guess what i want to
say is why are you so certain you want
to have that baby
oh the human yeah that human
the one that you're going to get from
raw dogging i think i've always wanted
kids
okay about seven of them but then once i
got the loads and just never got
pregnant
i kind of came to terms i guess i'm not
gonna have kids
so
i mean this sounds like a lot of come
you came to terms jesus christ got the
loads come to terms it's not as easy as
you think it is to have a kid even
though there's a billions and billions
of people over these years but oh yeah
the the money you gotta get the money
shot i'm talking about getting pregnant
oh that too yeah
and then people are like well i raw
dogged for eight years too and i got
pregnant when i least expected it just
i kind of want to expect it but
i probably won't you kind of want to be
with at least the guy you think like
this could be a dad oh for sure for sure
yeah i'm not just out there boning left
and right yeah
yeah
i mean if it's a little hook up
maybe i'll throw on a little condom but
not me him but
but
yeah i mean i'm not going to be in a
relationship using condoms that's going
to be itchy yeah that would be pointless
mm-hmm yeah
don't have time for condoms right now
now what about your boyfriend is he
worried about having kids he's cool
he's cool i don't think he's working i
don't think he's worried i'm gonna put
these on if we're in a relationship yeah
he
he probably wants kids more than me i'm
not trying to have kids honestly but
if it happens it happens
and i'm 27
i and my dad is 75
i'm like wait what i want to i wanted to
have kids for 40 years he was 48 when he
had you
yeah my mom was 25.
get the [ __ ] out hold up hold on that's
my i'm 40 i just turned 49 your mom was
25 when they got together and had a baby
yeah yeah four with her mm-hmm
so he was how was she when she was 21
when they had to first get together then
[ __ ]
or at least i'm thinking ashley is 30
34 35 [ __ ]
the math i have too many siblings that's
me with a 25 year old right now like
okay kudos to your dad he's probably had
something going on back then whatever
but they also have four kids with the 20
like the 25 year old to me at this age
would be enough you know what i'm saying
like yeah you know what that would be
good yeah but he already had kids too so
my mom like stepped in and was a step
mommy and then had us and then
yeah they grew their differences and
then my mom got remarried when i was
eight years old
and so like and is she still married to
that guy yeah and is he a good dude is
that your stepdad yeah gosh i have the
best [ __ ] stepdad
ever like
i would say i got raised with like three
parents you know
your dad and stepdad get along yeah
they'll go out to breakfast together
much younger as your stepdad than your
dad
he's around the city so they're like 50
i think he's like 52 my stepdad
yeah and
gosh he
has cancer
right now yeah
okay
blood cancer so
it's been a real big struggle for with
that too
yeah like
i
my mom called and was like yeah they
just gave him eight years so like oh my
god that's in the back of my head like
holy [ __ ] my mom's gonna be a widow like
there's a lot there's a lot in this
brand thinking you know go talk to
somebody i just need to go get some
ayahuasca and [ __ ] go to costa rica
and chill
uh
eat a bag of shrooms i need to eat a bag
of shrooms a big bag and but yeah i'm
just like you know you have that in your
brain like all these different things
and i actually tried to get him on
shrooms you did yeah i'm like
well it's fantastic fun guy like let's
get you on shrooms [ __ ] chemo like this
that but he is like so by the book
and
he owns an oil company in utah so damn
yeah so they're like
there's he wants to i think i don't know
what he wants to do but
she's young yeah and
he was he got really sick like he did
yeah so he was on chemo for like the
past year lost so much weight like and
then he had to stop working because he
was just so weak and like had to be on
an oxygen tank and
just like seeing him and like how much
he did for me and just took me under his
wing when i was you know when my parents
divorced and accepted me and just the
coolest [ __ ] guy so funny too
and just
it was rough just seeing him sick but
now he's doing chemo like once a month
and the health like
the health system is so [ __ ]
like you have to go in debt to
to die to die to die it's so [ __ ]
i hate it
i wish we could just change the let's
just change the health care system just
give it to people yeah yeah that need it
yeah wait in line and go in debt to die
yeah
and it's like you should just be able to
enjoy like if you find out how long you
have to live you should enjoy life
anyway but like damn now you have health
problems and
can't do anything about it you can't
even work and then you just feel
hopeless
and i i feel hopeless too it's like
cancer is oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] cancer for real for sure
and then my mom is so sweet too like
she's just like well we just have to
live these like we have to
just live you know i'm like let's go on
vacation let's go to the redwoods let's
do mushrooms let's [ __ ] go for sure
well
i want to first of all thank you for
coming on here and talking about this
this turned in to be a lot more
death than autism no but i love it i
mean listen man my whole growing up
up until my about your age was death
death death death
death and then it tailor off for a
little bit
and now i'm gonna be the next wave on
deck you know what i mean like death
that it's coming for all of us so yeah i
appreciate you being open and honest
about being so scared and vulnerable
about it oh yeah um all right it's your
first time here so i'm gonna ask you
after everything we've talked about
today advice you would give to your 16
year old self
life goes on
and everything will work out
all right you know everything works out
on its own
at the end of the day
promote whatever you'd like to promote
again please
all right
hello everybody
all right check out the viral podcast
on spotify or any any other major
streaming platforms out yonder uh
my instagram's page gin facebook page
gin snap me you can hop on my only fans
and see my pubes
they're out there
yeah do some pube updates oh i actually
did a asmr with my pubes what did you do
with them like crinkle them together i
was twisting them and then i got the mic
and like put it on there and it was like
i wish i could just play the audio
we maybe could but it was actually
pretty cool noises
my pubes are like four inches long right
now
did you know
yeah i didn't no i didn't know yeah i'll
have to show you
all right we'll wrap it up we'll go
check those out yeah come check out the
pubes
right man thank you as always ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you